la dénutrition c'est un manque d'apport
finalement au corps de protéines du coup
le corps est en rupture entre guillemets
de protéines ce qui enclenche du coup la
perte de masse musculaire un mauvais un
mauvais fonctionnement cellulaire etc et
qui est une réelle pathologie
[Musique]
les symptômes on a une fatigue une
manque un manque de mobilité surtout par
exemple chez les personnes âgées on a
une sédentarité qui qui s'installe
beaucoup c'est surtout sur les bilans
biologiques où on voit justement si la
personne était nutri ou non
c'est déjà réévaluer l'apport en fait en
protéines de la personne qui mange par
exemple pas assez de viande poisson œuf
de produits laitiers ou même de
protéines végétales donc c'est recalculé
en fait ces apports et la mettre en ce
qu'on appelle nous en régime en plan
alimentaire du coup hyper protéiné pour
avoir un rebond d'apport protéique dans
l'alimentation qui permettent de refaire
on va dire les stocks protéines du corps
quoi
[Musique]